new world has officially launched and so
many people are trying to play that the
servers are experiencing some issues
battlefield 2042 dates have been
announced and halo infinite's upcoming
beta is opening up the doors for a lot
more people so stick around to see if
you qualify i'm persia and this is your
gamespot news
new world amazon game studios long
delayed mmo is officially live and it
has quickly become the number two game
on steam with more than 700 000
concurrent players and counting
unfortunately that also means server
issues and long login cues for many
players looking to dive in most of the
games north american and european
servers are currently at high population
counts with a few still at medium
population amazon says it wants to get
everyone into the game and already
mentioned that it is setting up more
servers and actively working on the
issues the game is also seeing massive
popularity on twitch which is also owned
by amazon currently more than 750 000
people are watching new world on the
platform and those watching certain
channels and who link their steam
accounts can earn switch drops for
in-game items amazon game studios vice
president christoph hartman recently
said new world would be the game that
proved what the studio was capable of
and if the game's launch is any
indication it seems like amazon's
investment in the game space may soon
start paying off
ea and dice have officially announced
the open beta dates for battlefield 2042
and it's pretty soon as rumored the beta
officially begins on october 8th but
people who pre-order or subscribe to ea
play can start two days early beginning
october 6th since ea play is bundled
with xbox game pass ultimate subscribers
to microsoft service can start on
october 6th as well preloading for all
platforms regardless of pre-order status
begins on october 5th also of note all
progress from the open beta will be
wiped ahead of launch as is normal for
betas like this however a lot of weapons
and vehicles will be unlocked for
players to try in the beta you can also
look forward to checking out
battlefield's famous conquest mode on
the new orbital map which was featured
in the battlefield 2042 reveal trailer
conquest sees two teams of 64 players or
32 on ps4 and xbox one competing for
control over massive rocket launch pads
spread across the map four specialist
characters will be available in the beta
which include boris casper falk and
mckay you'll also get a chance to see
how progression and cosmetics work in
battlefield 2042 that means a first
glimpse of how much xp you'll be earning
the different ways you'll be able to
earn it in gameplay the return of
ribbons and all new features like the
player card more xp is rewarded to
players who play the objectives and
stick with their teams and squads until
the match ends followed by further
various actions such as kills assists
and other support actions like spotting
once you earn enough xp you are promoted
to the next player level and with every
new level comes new rewards including
weapons gadgets cosmetics and more
cosmetics will be broken down buying
rarity battlefield 2042 will also have a
cross progression functionality which
will be shared across all platforms and
travel with you wherever you go as long
as you play on the same ea account this
means your unlock progress and completed
purchases in your playstation copy of
the game will carry on over to the xbox
or pc version and vice versa playstation
plus is not required for the battlefield
2042 open beta but for xbox users you
will need to have that xbox gold
subscription so make sure you have that
ready if you want to hop in there are
even more details about the beta that we
have up on gamespot.com right now if you
want to check it out
the weekend's upcoming halo infinite
multiplayer beta which is showing off 16
battle for the very first time is going
to be opening its doors to a much larger
audience than in past tests xbox users
can get access by downloading the xbox
insider hub app which is free to
download you do not need to be a member
of the halo insider program to get
access but you can still sign up for
that program to be eligible for
additional beta tests and other
offerings the xbox insider app is only
on xbox but 343's brian gerrard said the
team has another solution to invite more
pc players on steam if you're already in
the halo insider program then a friend
code will be provided to you that you
can share with someone to redeem on pc
or on xbox part of the reason 343 is
opening this new beta test to everyone
is to stress test the servers with the
ultimate goal being to help bring the
servers down the full schedule for week
2 includes multiple modes including
capture the flag total control and
slayer on one map fragmentation
the beta will be available in two four
hour pieces each day running october 1st
through 3rd and content from the
previous beta including for before arena
slayer will also be available during
weekend 2.
we basically have two heavy hitting
betas back to back halo infinite and a
battlefield 2042 let me know in the
comments which one you're looking
forward to the most and of course leave
a like and subscribe so you don't miss
your next gamespot news update thank you
so much for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you